بقوله ان طهران تتطلع الى
استئناف العلاقات مع الرياض
السودانية وكأن هذه المعارضة
سعودية وليست مصرية. فماذا تركتم
البحر الاحمر. فضلا عن عدم
منافساتها في حل الازمة
فهل حان الوقت لان يجتمع العرب
ويهتم بانفسهم ويترك الغرب
العاكر. في الثاني والعشرين
فبراير الفين وثلاثة وعشرين
اعلنها وزير الخارجية الايراني.
حسين امير عبد اللهيان للعالم
العسيرة? حتى ان الموقع
البريطاني اشار الى معلومات تفيد
يمكن سدادها. مهلا مهلا ايتها
الرياض فالامر لم يصل لهذه
ويتمثل الشرط الثالث بوقف دعم
اقامة قاعدة روسية في السودان.
على مصر لشركة ارامكو السعودية
للنفط والمتعلقة بشحنات النفط
لعودة الامور الى مجاريها بين
المملكة ومصر. ومن هذه الشروط
وتشمل الشروط منح السعودية حق
استضافة المراكز الرئيسية لمنتدى
تسريع نقل السيادة الى جزيرتي
تيران وصنافير الى السعودية.
يتركون الخليجيون اشقائهم
المصريين اليوم في ازمتهم
ان القاهرة فوجئت بمطالبة الرياض
بسداد الديون القديمة المستحقة
رئيس تحرير صحيفة الجمهورية
الرسمية. اما الشرط الثاني فيشمل
وثلاثة عشر. بحسب موقع ميدال
ايست مونيتور. البريطاني. فلماذا
العربية. واذا كانت السعودية
ودول الخليج قد قدموا اكثر من
العليا بحكمها الصادر في عام
الفين سبعة عشر. والى اليوم لم
المصرية المتواجدة خارج البلاد.
مشيرة الى خمسة شروط سعودية
الجزيرتين. وايدتها في ذلك دائرة
فحص الطعون بالمحكمة الادارية
يتم تسليم الجزيرتين للسعودية
ليتضح هنا احد اسباب التوتر
لواء يا هؤلاء. لكن وعلى كل حال
فالعرب عموما ونحن خصوصا مع كل
تتنفس الصعداء قليلا. برجوعها
الى محكمة القضاء الاداري في
ايرانية لتصحيح علاقات البلدين
ايضا. واسرائيل بين فكي كماشة.
ومصر تشهد منعطفا قد تصطدم فيه
مصالح الجانبين ببعضها البعض.
الجزيرتين تقعان داخل الحدود
البحرية السعودية. ماذا? نعم. ما
بكلمة من هنا وتصريح من هناك. ان
مصر مترددة بشأن تسليم ادارة
الشرق الاوسط واحد اقوى الجيوش
في العالم. والسعودية لها ثروات
الحدود البحرية بين البلدين.
وطبقا لبنود الاتفاقية فان
والاسرائيليون يحلمون بتشتيت
الشمل العربي. فهل يتركون مصر
في مصر وشعبها ام ان لهم مآرب
اخرى. لن تبحث تل ابيب الا عن
والسعودية لتشكلان عمودا فقريا
لقوة عربية لا تقهر? لكن صفعة
مصلحتها يا اصدقاء. فمصر تمتلك
اقوى جيش عربي بل اقوى جيش في
العلاقة بين الماضي والحاضر.
خلال العقود الماضية مر العلاقات
احدث التصريحات العربية واكثرها
جدلا. نعم. ها هو فنان السعودي
متابعينا? ولنعد الى موضوعنا.
فيبدو ان العلاقات بين السعودية
الجزيرتين للمملكة. لكن هل كل
تلك التصريحات الاسرائيلية حبا
قرار نقل ملكية الجزيرتين
للسعودية. وهنا تتدخل اسرائيل
وسبعة عشر. وصادق عليه الرئيس
المصري عبدالفتاح السيسي على
اصابة هذا العمود الفقري العربي.
من له مصلحة في ذلك? لتظهر هنا
اليوم لكل العرب هي بيت العرب.
مضيفا ان كانت مصر ام الدنيا
جزيرتي تيران وسنافير. لتعود
الجزيرتان الى الاحضان المصرية
للمنطقة العربية. وهنا نطرح
سؤالا للعرب. من ذا الذي يرغب في
المصرية السعودية بمحطات من المد
والجزر. ليتوقع الكثيرون ان تظل
دولة بعينها. الا ان هناك سعودية
واضحة نحو مصر. اي الودائع
السعودية لمصر ستكون مشروطة بعد
اليوم. فعن اي شروط يتحدثون. هنا
وحماية. حتى ظهرت السعودية
مطالبة مصر بتبعية الجزيرتين في
من ابريل الفين وستة عشر. عندما
وقعت مع مصر اتفاقية تعيين
هو اعظم من السياسة والاقتصاد.
نعم. انها الجغرافيا. انها
فالسعودية ابوها. فهل السعودية
حقا هي ابو العرب برأيكم
والسياق الاقتصادي ليس الوحيد
الحاضر في توتر العلاقات بين
تلك المعارك الكلامية بين
الاعلاميين حبيسة المنصات
الرقمية. فثمة من يصف العلاقات
المصرية السعودية بالعمود الفقري
استراتيجية بلاده في تقديم
المساعدات لحلفائها دون شروط.
وتسعمائة واثنين وخمسين. اما ما
اثار الموضوع حقا هي التصريحات
يعود في جذره الاول الى انها لم
تغادر عباءة العسكر منذ عام الف
لا تقوم قائمة للعرب. من هنا
كانت البداية. بعد سنوات من
ليحصي اسباب وقوع مصر اسيرة
لصندوق النقد الدولي. قائلا ان
المشاحنة من جديد قائلا ان ما
يحصل لمصر في السنوات الاخيرة
غرار تركي الحمد. هنا خالد
الدخيل كاتب سعودي سياسي يعيد
وعلى حين غرة. وركوبا لموجة
التوتر بين البلدين. بل وعلى
ماليا. وذاك يرد الجميل سياسيا.
والامور ماشية زي الفل. كما
بعد لايضاح الوضع الحالي لعلاقات
القاهرة والرياض. فخرجت المعارضة
النقطة بعد. هل هي حقيقة ام ان
الموقع البريطاني يتصيد في الماء
قبل نحو خمس سنوات كان نظام
السيسي يعتقد ان النفط منحة لا
تسعين مليار دولار منذ استيلاء
الجيش على السلطة في صيف الفين
الاعلام ساحة للسجال. خبر بعد
اخر ورد بعد تصريح. الم ينتهي
خصوصا مع تدهور العملة المحلية
المصرية في الوقت الراهن.
يذكر بافضال بلده على الاخر. كل
ذلك متزامن مع صمت مطبق للسلطات
طرف عربي واخر ايراني ليحبس
الصهاينة انفاسهم. لكن اسرائيل
امر من شأنه ان يجمع الشقيقتين
مرة اخرى للعودة قبلة للدول
الاخيرة لمساعدة مصر. ويا له من
رفض. ترك الاشقاء في موقف صعب
الحالي بين الشقيقتين العربيتين.
شروط مصرية. ليس هناك شيء رسمي
لتأتي شمرة الرد المصري. بحذف
الكاتب السعودي تغريداته تلك.
المواضيع في بلدك. ودعك من
الجارة المصرية. هكذا كان
للبلدين. اما كان عليك ان تتطرق
لمواضيع اخرى يا هذا فهناك مئات
مصر. التي اصدرت حكمها عام الفين
وستة عشر ببطلان توقيع اتفاقية
عربية اصابت اسرائيل في مقتل.
السعودية تعيد المياه لمجاريها
مع ايران. العدو الشرس
للاسرائيليين. مع مفاوضات مصر
والسعودية ومصر. وكذلك دور بغداد
في الوساطة بشأن الاتفاق النووي.
والقاهرة مثمنا الدور العراقي في
تعزيز الحوار والتعاون بين ايران
المصريون يتساءلون. لكن تركي
الحمد غاص في الامر بطريقة جريئة
سمعتموه هو ما جرى رسميا وحرفيا.
واقره البرلمان المصري عام الف
القاهرة والرياض. بحسب ما نقله
موقع اوكسيوس الامريكي. فهناك ما
اقالة جميع الاعلامي الذين
تصدروا التراشق الاعلامي لا سيما
واوروبا بقطع النفط وقتلت مصر
ومعها العرب في جيش واحد. واليوم
اكثر من مناسبة. لكن لم يلتفت
احد للمطالب السعودية حتى الثامن
التراب والوطن. عام الف وتسعمائة
وسبعة وستين استطاعت مصر استعادة
النوم في العسل للبلدين ومطلع
هذا العام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين.
نفطية هائلة تتحكم باقتصادات
العالم صعودا وهبوطا.
والاعرق والاكثر ثراء والاكثر
تقدما. وذلك بقوله ان السعودية
محمد عبده. يدخل خطا شائكا وتغوص
قدماه في رمال صحراء الافضل
الرسمية. هنا وزير المالية
السعودي محمد الجدعان. يعلن تغير
اولم يكن الجيش هذا الدرع الحامي
والضامن لام الدنيا. لينهال سيل
الاوضاع الاقتصادية في مصر.
ليربك السياسة الاعلامية
وعلى الرغم من ان خطاب الجدعان
كان في سياق عام. ولم يشر الى
انه كيان الاحتلال. فلا يكتفي
بجرائمه في فلسطين. بل يخطط ان
اتضح الامر اكثر. والسعوديون
يرفضون دعوة صندوق النقد الدولي
المصريون. لكن هناك من يدس السم
في العسل. هل علمتم من هم? نعم.
ومصر. وما علاقة الكيان
الاسرائيلي بالامر? فقد وقفوا
يوما في خندق واحد وفي واحد.
هناك عاقبت المملكة امريكا
فما الذي يجري بين ام الدنيا
وقبلة المسلمين? ونقصد السعودية
الرسمية للبلدين. فالى اين ايها
الاشقاء? العديد من التساؤلات
مني انا الاول. العلاقة السعودية
المصرية علاقة صلبة قوية. ما
اليوم في مصر ازور بعض المواقع
في مصر اجد المسؤولين من اكبرهم
العربي يترك اخاه ليواجه مصيره.
رسائل مبطنة تنتشر على سماء
من الردود المصرية على الاكاديمي
السعودي. انه تدخل غير مقبول في
اهم تلك الاسباب هي سيطرة الجيش
على دوائر الدولة ومفاصلها. لكن
الشأن المصري. ومليء بالمغالطات
يا هذا. هكذا كان الرد المصري.
اكاديمي سعودي يدعى تركي الحمد
يطلق سبع تغريدات تطرق الى
شقاقا اخر. فلديهم ما يكفيهم من
المشاكل. ان موعد تصفية النفوسية
هؤلاء. عن الاخوة الاعداء نتحدث
بقية. توتر الاشقاء. فضاء
جزيرة العرب. هكذا هو حال كبيرتي
العرب مصر والسعودية مع تحول
القنوات الى ساحة لتصفية
الحسابات لفظي مستعر ومتبادل. كل
تطرح والتكهنات تملأ المكان. فما
الذي يجري بين القاهرة والرياض?
الى فترة قريبة كان البلدان
كالسمن على العسل. فذا يدعم ذا
سحابة صيف وستمر ام ان للاشقاء
رأي اخر? فالعرب لا يحتملون
الزمن التجريح يا اصدقاء؟ معارك
سيادية. ازمات اقتصادية صعبة.
ننساش وقفة اشقاءنا معنا. ام
الدنيا وابوها. الاشقاء
الى اصغرهم يبكون. اللي عايز
يلعب في بث ويضيعها لازم يخلص
لم يعد حال الاشقاء يسر الصديق.
ولكن ها هو يفرح العدو. هل هي
الاصدقاء. التوتر يخيم على
الاجواء ورائحة النزاعات تفوح.
والاسرائيليين وراء ظهورهم. ما
الذي ترونه انتم